I grew up reviewing writers this is
largely because I came of age in the 70s
when Francis Coppola and Mario Puzo were
writing The Godfather and Robert Towne
was writing Chinatown and Frank Pearson
was writing Dog Day Afternoon paddy
Chayefsky was writing Network and the
hospital and William Goldman was writing
all the President's Men in Butch Cassidy
throw in rocky by Sylvester Stallone and
The Omen by David Seltzer and the
candidate by Jeremy larner Kramer vs
Kramer by Robert Benton jaws by Peter
Benchley and Carl Gottlieb and of course
Annie Hall in Manhattan by Woody Allen
and Marshall Brickman you've got the
beginning of a Writers Hall of Fame
these people were heroes to me but I
also grew up reviewing writers because
my father represented them he was a
literary agent a great one and when I
was 19 I walked into his office and
announced that I decided I was gonna be
a screenwriter he said come with me
back in those days literary agencies
kept their their clients scripts on
paper and in the back of my father's
office there was a large storeroom with
these huge metal shelves that were
stacked high with scripts on one of
those shelves were the scripts of his
client Alvin Sargent who had written
Julia and Paper Moon my father pulled
down Alvin's brilliant shooting
screenplay for ordinary people and he
handed to me he said here do this and
that's where he was setting the bar for
me and I've been trying to hit it ever
since
because WGA rules require that any
successful screenwriter starts out
struggling so that he'll have a story to
tell later I spent the first three years
out of school as Gail mentioned doing a
regular job by day and writing at night
but shortly after I had worked for Gail
I caught a little bit of fire and became
a bit of the flavor of the month and
pretty soon I found myself writing two
movies for a big-time producer at
Universal and I was getting treated
beautifully one day I walked into his
office for a meeting and there was a
piece of paper spitting out of his
dot-matrix printer for those of you not
familiar with the technology this was
the late 80s
on this page was a list and at the top
of the list were two letters a a and
beside it was the name of his wife and
his lawyer and I realized I was looking
at his Christmas list and a voice in me
said Billy stop reading because you
don't want to know where you are on this
list you don't want to know what letter
you are but several weeks later a
Christmas gift arrived from this
producers office and it was this
beautiful silver tray with a gingerbread
house on it that was inlaid with candies
and lights was fantastic and I thought
to myself well I'm not a a but I'm a and
I'm only 25 that's pretty good during
the course of the next year both movies
that I was writing for him went in to
turn around and as Christmas time rolled
around I found myself thinking I don't
think there's another silver tray coming
for me this year but soon a messenger
from his office came and presented me
with this great gift basket and inside
the gift basket was a bottle of wine and
salami and some cheese and I thought to
myself you know what I'm not a but I'm
still B and I'm only 26 that's not so
bad
and I were later I got a call from a
panic desist in who work for this
producer said did you get a gift from us
he said yes I did so don't open it I
said why not he said we've got your gift
mixed up with somebody else I said well
it's okay I mean he got mine I got his
it's really fine I said don't open it
someone's coming over right now he hung
up still palpitating and ten minutes
later I hear a screech of tires outside
my apartment and the frantic steps of
this panicked assistant as he pounds his
way up the stairs to my door where he
pounded and I answered and there he is
ashen-faced he says you have it and I
give him the gift basket and he handed
me a tin of yogurt-covered pretzels
when people ask me what it's like to be
a young screenwriter in Hollywood that's
the story that I tell them in other
words
nickels fellows I am now officially
welcoming you into the fraternity of
screenwriters which means it's my job
both to congratulate you and to warn you
about what's out there ten years ago or
even five this warning would have been
simple back then when screenwriters get
to got together to [ __ ] which was often
it was usually about directors for being
bullies or for trying to steal a shared
screenplay by credit or cutting
necessary dialogue or just playing
botching things but that's not the case
anymore the sands under all of us have
shifted now and today directors even the
arrogant ones are voting scared like
everybody else
today the warning is actually about the
business itself and the almost
pathological timidity of the
institutions that control it when I
started writing there were still a few
Mavericks out there a few gunslingers
who were running studios these were
people who went with their guts and
would make a movie just because they
believed in it but that's not the
process anymore today before a studio
chair can greenlight a movie that movie
must also be blessed by the head of
marketing and the head of foreign sales
and the head of home video it must be
subjected to a process called running
the numbers which means that that movies
cost or downside is compared as compared
against its potential value because of
its cast and because of what might do in
foreign markets of course this process
takes into account every variable except
the variable which actually matters the
one that can't possibly be gauged by any
sort of calculus which is whether or not
the movie is going to be any good and
yet the process continues there are
challenges there are other challenges
too ones born in progress itself it's
axiomatic now that the technology of
moviemaking has never been greater than
it is today
but I don't think any of us can honestly
say that movies themselves have never
been greater and these things are not
unrelated suppose that we were going to
shoot a scene of this very ceremony in
this very room we can now if we want to
add elements to the
scene to make it more visually arresting
we could light the ceiling on fire by
using CGI we could enhance the
experience by projecting it in 3d does
any of this have anything to do with
story or character no but it would look
great in the trailer that kind of
thinking the idea that dazzling visuals
are enough has led to a certain kind of
moviemaking laziness that has not been
good for anybody
worse it's made it tougher and tougher
to dazzle the audience because they know
out there now that we're making movies
with software instead of cameras and
when any image is possible no image is
all that impressive anymore we're
storytellers which means we have to do
better sometimes I think we have to
rescue the business from the very people
who own it the good news is we can
inside every one of you Nichols fellows
is the flame that has always lived away
in this industry which is originality
that one spark of an idea that one
archetypal character or story or truth
or world that no one's ever captured
before you remember the movie wall-e the
brilliant Pixar film he's in a dangerous
world he's one of thousands who were
supposed to clean it up but there's
something special about wall-e he finds
this little tiny sprig which one which
might one day become a plant and he
guards it and saves it and preserves it
on the chance that it might someday turn
into something beautiful
well Hollywood is that dangerous world
and you are wall-e
and your idea is that plant and you have
to protect it if you do it might change
the world
that's your charge now greatness you
have to pursue it every single day in
everything that you do in your work
ethic in the way that you conduct
yourself and who you choose to do
business with and whether or not you
learn from them you are now a part of
the most collaborative medium anywhere
in the world and much of your success in
it is going to be determined by how well
you listen I was very fortunate in that
regard as the child of divorced parents
I learned early how to take two warring
factions and make them both feel that
they'd been heard this works fantastic
in meetings
you're gonna get a lot of notes in your
career and it'll be your instinct to
resent them but I'm telling you now to
ignore this instinct the fact is that
most of the notes that you get will be
smart and thoughtful and all of them
even the bad ones will teach you
something about where you fail to
articulate something as clearly as you
had as you had it in your head or where
something just didn't make it on the
page where something just didn't land
you will make your living largely not by
writing but by rewriting and the grace
and efficiency with which you do that
will define you we will mostly define
you more than anything else is what
projects you say yes to and what project
you say no to here's a rule of thumb
about that if someone offers you a job
on a project that has real heat a star
attached to it or some wonderful
pedigree and you find that you're not
waking you're not waking up every
morning thinking about it if it's not
living inside of you trying to claw its
way out then don't write it remember
that you got here by believing in
original thinking never forget that and
always remember that if you are inspired
we will be - the best advice I ever
heard about writing came from Paddy
Chayefsky he of the aforementioned
Network and the hospital he also wrote
Marty that's three Oscars Chayefsky
advice to writers was simple don't think
of it as art think of it as work because
when a writer is stuck and he or she
calls it another writer for help that
second writer doesn't say what's the art
problem that second writer says what's
not working and they get under the hood
and they fix it together that's most of
what you'll do in your career work
problem solving approach it in that way
and then at the end of every day you'll
at least be able to say I did my job
today and if you're an artist it'll come
out as art anyway the truth is there are
millions of variables that will
profoundly affect your career variables
over which you have zero control you
have no control about over the state of
the economy or over the health of our
industry
you have no say and whether or not the
DVD business flatlines or whether or not
the market is suddenly ripe for
thrillers or superhero movies or
god help us romantic comedies the only
variable you are at you will ever have
any control over is your willingness to
work hard so maximize that variable I
take my son to his bus stop every
morning at 7:30 I'm at my desk working
by 8:00 somebody feeds me at 1:00 and
I'm back at my desk by 1:30 working
until 6:00 I don't surf the web I don't
gamble online I don't go to the local
Starbucks for two hours I don't try to
seek out old girlfriends on Facebook I
don't do anything that requires time I
just work I do this because there's a
mountain top that I'm trying to get to
and I'm nowhere near it I can see it
from here at the accomplishments of
those writers that I mentioned earlier
that's the holy grail for me I want to
leave a legacy like they did I want to
spend a lot of time in tuxedos the next
time the da fi does a list of the
hundred greatest movies of all time I
want my name on board on one of them at
least
and I want someday in 2032 for someone
standing right here making this speech
to cite one of my movies with the same
kind of reverence that I have for those
movies of the 70s luck will not get me
there although I will need plenty of it
the only thing that will get me there is
my willingness to write that fifteenth
raft or proofread it one more time or be
open to notes from someone who's smarter
than I am it may be that I'll be getting
notes from one of you Nichols fellows
one day and I trust that they'll be good
ones I'll leave you with one last
thought as you surge forward don't
forget to look back at the writers guild
building on 3rd and Fairfax there's a
library and in that library you can read
any screenplay that you'd ever want to
read visit that library it's your
history up on those shelves the bar that
was set for you
by the writers that have preceded you
their triumphs their struggles they
belong to you now cherish them learn
from them let them challenge you to keep
getting better it's true there will be a
tin of yogurt-covered pretzels or two
thrown your way
but if you keep trying and if you keep
fighting it might one day be replaced on
yourself by an Oscar I wish you nothing
but the best and I thank you very much